well ladies and gentlemen we're not
going to keep you in suspense anymore
we're going to tell you right now about
the scientific and technical awards and
to make the experience even more
pleasurable for you here are a man and a
woman and pretty fine examples they are
she's an international star of over 50
film is an actor author and brand new
American citizen miss Joan Collins and
Arnold Schwarzenegger
a few nights ago we attended the
ceremonies at the Beverly Hilton at
which the Oscar works for scientific and
technical achievements were presented
here's a look at that evenings events
which began with the awarding of plaques
and certificates to 14 recipients in
nine technical categories it was my
honor to present an Oscar for the
development of the xenon projection lamp
which increased the efficiency and
economy in theaters all over the world
dr. Curt Lachey's Oscar was accepted by
Lawrence P power dr. Lachey has whose 80
years old has indicated that this
represents the highlight of his 37-year
career at Osram thank you it's really
wonderful then it is my turn
one of the most prestigious awards and
the entire scientific field we would
need a very large Oscar to engrave it
all this one reads simply the Gordon is
Sawyer award and below that is the
recipients name dr. John G frame was
awarded for a lifetime devoted to the
techniques of sound recording and
reproduction and this gentleman's work
stretches back nearly 70
since long before there were sound films
John frame was involved in a science of
sound
many of the Spears
I still use today I remember reading
back in the little grade school back in
Ireland many years ago about eighty
years ago lines from the Alexander
Alexander Pope's
as a young man in which he said Grave
wits to to madness are near allied and
ten partitions do their bounds divided I
thank you all of us we appreciate
fathers in the heart of motion pictures
appreciate the contributions of those
scientists and technicians
our congratulations to all those winners
many thanks for the great work in the
motion picture business
thank you
that should answer the question once and
for all where's the beef
I'll leave it up to you whom I'm talking
about